This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the show this week, we're bringing you an episode of a new podcast called La Brega. And to tell us about this series is Alana Casanova Burgess. Host and co-creator and producer of La Brega, stories of the Puerto Rican experience, co-production from WNYC Studios and Fuludo Studios. Say that in my dreams now. The name of the show, La Brega, is a word in Puerto Rican Spanish that doesn't really have a great English translation.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在本周的节目中，我们将为您带来一档名为《拉布雷加》（La Brega）的新播客节目。向我们介绍这个系列的是阿拉娜·卡萨诺瓦-伯吉斯（Alana Casanova Burgess）。她是《拉布雷加》的主持人、联合创始人和制作人，这是一档讲述波多黎各人经历的节目，由纽约公共广播电台工作室（WNYC Studios）和富卢多工作室（Fuludo Studios）联合制作。我现在做梦都会念这段了。节目的名字“拉布雷加”（La Brega）是波多黎各西班牙语中的一个词，在英语中很难找到一个完美的翻译。
But to illustrate the concept, we're going to start with a cell phone video that was taken in the aftermath of Hurricane Maria when the people of Puerto Rico were living in the dark. Some Puerto Ricans were without electricity for months on end, and everyone had to find ways to cope. And in the video, two people are standing in a carport. And so a woman is recording her father,
但为了说明这个概念，我们将从一段手机视频开始，这段视频拍摄于玛丽亚飓风过后，当时波多黎各人民生活在黑暗之中。一些波多黎各人连续几个月没有电力供应，每个人都不得不寻找应对的方法。视频中，两个人站在车棚里。一个女人正在记录她的父亲，
and they're showing off this invention. Here we can find the neighborhood where we're going down the mountain, with the ceiling of a puppy. They've got like the body, the drum of a washing machine. And then in the middle, what do you call that? The like, spoke that comes out of the middle of the washing machine. The agitator, the spinner or something? The agitator, that is correct. I think I had googled that.
他们在炫耀这个发明。在这里我们可以找到我们下山时经过的那个社区，用小狗的天花板。他们有一个像洗衣机滚筒一样的身体。然后中间那个，你叫它什么来着？就像从洗衣机中间伸出来的那个，轮辐？波导器、旋转器什么的？波导器，没错。我想我之前谷歌过这个。
The agitator has bicycle handlebars attached to it. We've got a month lavando in the famous Visi lavadora. Visi Lavadora. Bisi Lavadora. And this woman's father is so excited to show off this Bisi Lavadora. So he's moving the handlebars back and forth and showing how it froths up, how you get a good lather in the soak. And they're just making like the most of this terrible situation. So they're exclaiming like, look, it washes so well. You don't have electricity, but you don't
波导器上装有自行车把手。我们在著名的“自行车洗衣机”（Visi Lavadora）里洗了一个月。“自行车洗衣机”。“自行车洗衣机”。这个女人的父亲非常兴奋地展示这台“自行车洗衣机”。所以他前后移动把手，展示它是如何起泡的，如何在浸泡中洗出丰富的泡沫。他们只是在充分利用这个糟糕的状况。所以他们大喊着，看，洗得多干净。你没有电，但你不需要电。
need it. And you get a workout while you're doing it. And they're just like having a funny time, you know, Puerto Ricans are really creative. I know everybody says that about themselves. We're such a creative people. But you're all wrong is the thing. Look, low key flex, but we've been through a lot. And so there's this sort of celebration in the video. And then at the same time, I knew, like I knew from talking
而且你在做这件事的同时还能锻炼身体。他们只是在度过一段有趣的时光，你知道的，波多黎各人真的很有创意。我知道每个人都这么说自己。我们是一个如此有创意的民族。但事实是你们都错了。看，低调地炫耀一下，但我们经历了很多。因此，视频中有一种庆祝的氛围。与此同时，我从与自己家人的交谈中知道，
to my own family members, how raw your hands get from like washing everything by hand in water, how like everybody just had to do the most for months. Like my aunt didn't have electricity for nine months. Wow. Right. So they can't get power back for themselves. They can't like reconnect the electricity because the infrastructure is so poor and the government
用手在水里洗所有的东西会让你的双手变得多么生红，每个人都不得不在好几个月里付出最大的努力。比如我阿姨有九个月没有电。哇。没错。所以他们无法为自己恢复电力。他们无法重新接通电源，因为基础设施太落后了，而政府又让他们失望了。
is failing them. But they find this workaround so that their hands don't have to crack after weeks and then what will become months of washing your laundry by hand. And so when I was thinking about how to describe the name of the series, La Brega, to listeners. One of the first things that popped up was this YouTube video that I watched like three years ago. So what is La Brega? Can you define it for us? Sure. It is a word that Puerto Ricans use all the time. It's this like catch all word for, I'm struggling with something, I'm in the hustle,
但他们找到了这种变通方法，这样他们在手洗了几个星期甚至几个月之后，手就不会裂开了。所以当我在思考如何向听众描述这个系列的名称“拉布雷加”（La Brega）时。我脑海中浮现的第一件事就是我大约三年前看过的这个YouTube视频。那么，什么是“拉布雷加”？你能为我们定义一下吗？当然。这是一个波多黎各人经常使用的词。这是一个包罗万象的词，意思是，我在为什么事苦苦挣扎，我在拼搏，
I'm in the situation that I can't solve, I can't actually like have any resolution to it, right? So for example, you can't solve the problem that you don't have electricity, but you can like attach some bicycle handlebars to the agitator of your washing machine and you can kind of make do Maybe you have a terrible boss. You can't fix that problem. You can't resolve it But you're like, all right. I'm just like I'm grappling with it. I think grappling is a good one
我处于一种无法解决的境地，我无法真正找到任何解决办法，对吧？例如，你无法解决你没有电的问题，但你可以把一些自行车把手装到洗衣机的波导器上，你就可以勉强应付过去。也许你有一个糟糕的老板。你无法解决这个问题。你无法解决它，但你会想，好吧，我只是在与之搏斗。我觉得“搏斗”这个词很贴切。
And but we use it all the time and I think I only really realized this after Maria, I was reporting for on the media. And I was able to actually make a montage of, I was asking people like, how are you doing though? Like, but how are you doing really? Which is a hard question to ask whenever, but like, nobody really wants to get into their feelings because how do you then crawl out of them? And people would say, like, oh, you know, you got to get used to it. I get a c'est, and I was like, wow, we get used
而且我们经常使用它，我想我只有在玛丽亚飓风之后才真正意识到这一点，当时我在为“媒体观察”（On the Media）做报道。我实际上能够制作一个蒙太奇，我问人们，不过你们过得怎么样？但是，你们真的过得怎么样？无论何时，这都是一个很难回答的问题，但没有人真正想陷入自己的情绪中，因为那样你怎么能从中爬出来呢？人们会说，哦，你知道的，你得习惯它。我习惯了，而我想，哇，我们太习惯各种事情了。
to things. Yeah. Like a lot. And that doesn't seem entirely healthy all the time. And there's this like celebration of resilience, like, oh, Puerto Ricans are so resilient, we're so resilient. But like, why are we resilient? And then comes that word, like, how are you doing? Well, a key en la brega, bregando. Why? You're also just coping and hustling and grappling with something instead of resolving, solving it.
是的。就像很多事情一样。而且这看起来并不总是完全健康的。人们对韧性有一种庆祝，比如，哦，波多黎各人太有韧性了，我们太有韧性了。但是，为什么我们要这么有韧性呢？然后这个词就出现了，比如，你最近怎么样？嗯，在苦撑，在拼搏。为什么？你其实也只是在应付、拼搏和与某些事情搏斗，而不是去解决它。
I mean, this is evidence, and the fact that, you know, we have to talk for a long time to define this thing. That it's kind of hard to define in English. Like there isn't like an easy equivalent. What do you think that is? I don't know, but I would love to loan this word. Like what has the pandemic been, if not for like one long break up? But fair, yeah, totally. So you've made a whole podcast series called La Brega.
我的意思是，这就是证据，事实上，你知道的，我们需要聊很长时间来定义这个东西。在英语中很难定义它。就像没有一个简单的对等词一样。你认为这是为什么？我不知道，但我很乐意借用这个词。如果这不是一场漫长的分手，那这场大流行算什么？不过说得对，完全同意。所以你制作了一个名为《拉布雷加》的播客系列。
Tell us what motivated you to make it and what you wanted to accomplish with the series. We wanted to tell really rich, beautifully told stories about a place that really doesn't get talked about very often on our own terms. We hear about whether it should be a state, what the Democrats want, what the Republicans want. But very rarely are we talking about our own experience with, for example, austerity policy. You know, like, what does that look like?
告诉我们是什么促使你制作它，以及你希望通过这个系列实现什么目标。我们想以我们自己的方式，讲述关于一个经常不被提及的地方的丰富、精彩的故事。我们听到的是关于它是否应该成为一个州、民主党想要什么、共和党想要什么。但我们很少谈论我们自己对例如紧缩政策的经历。你知道的，那是什么样的？
What does our own history look like? Why do our suburbs look the way they do? Just like making everything about ourselves. And so, you know, we put together this team, we've got musicians and artists and reporters and producers and editors who are both from the diaspora and from the island because you know, it is a really complicated identity and so we wanted to marry those two parts of ourselves together and make like one team, like one avenger squad. one avenger squad. And at the same time, we wanted to talk to ourselves, obviously. And so early on in production, we realized like we've got to make these episodes in both English and Spanish, so that we don't leave anybody out. That's so cool. So like, if you go to the Lebrega
我们自己的历史是什么样的？为什么我们的郊区是这个样子的？就像把一切都和我们自己联系起来一样。所以，你知道的，我们组建了这个团队，我们有音乐家、艺术家、记者、制作人和剪辑师，他们既有来自海外侨民，也有来自岛上居民，因为你知道，这是一个非常复杂的身份，所以我们想把我们身上的这两个部分结合在一起，组成一个团队，就像一个复仇者联盟。一个复仇者联盟。与此同时，很明显，我们也想和我们自己对话。所以在制作的早期，我们意识到我们需要用英语和西班牙语制作这些 episodes，这样我们就不会落下任何人。太酷了。所以，如果你去《拉布雷加》的节目源，你会发现英语版本和西班牙语版本并排在一起。
feed, you will find English language and Spanish language versions through their side-by-side. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You can pick the one you want to listen to. We've been hearing that a lot of people listen to both of them and then find like the Easter eggs, like the details that change. They're different between them. Yeah, or couples where one person speaks one language better than the other. They listen together and then discuss. Love it.
对，对，对。你可以选择你想听的那一个。我们听说很多人把两个版本都听了，然后去寻找“复活节彩蛋”，比如那些改变的细节。它们之间是不同的。是的，或者有些伴侣，其中一个人比另一个人更擅长某种语言。他们一起听然后进行讨论。太喜欢了。
Yeah, I love it too. So we're going to feature one of the stories that you made for the series. And fittingly to 99% of us, it's the one about the Levittown in Puerto Rico, sort of the built environment to the story of the series. So to start, what is Levittown and what's your family's connection to the place? Well, we say Levittown, but it's spelled the same way as levitown in New York say on Long Island. Yes. And for people who don't know, levitowns were these mass-produced suburbs. They're like kind of the model suburbs, and there's one in New York, and there's one in Pennsylvania.
是的，我也很喜欢。所以我们要播放你为这个系列制作的一个故事。顺理成章地，对于我们这99%的人来说，它是关于波多黎各莱维顿（Levittown）的故事，可以说是该系列的建筑环境故事。首先，什么是莱维顿？你的家族和这个地方有什么联系？嗯，我们说的是莱维顿（Levittown），但它的拼写和纽约长岛的莱维顿（Levittown）是一样的。是的。对于那些不知道的人来说，莱维顿是那些大规模生产的郊区。它们有点像模范郊区，纽约有一个，宾夕法尼亚州也有一个。
And it was news to me that there's one in Puerto Rico too. So... Built by the same company. Built by the same company. Can you tell us a little bit about the Levitones in general and what they were made, what the point of Levitones were in the US in Puerto Rico? I think that their purpose was slightly different in Puerto Rico, but in New York, their purpose was post-war cheap housing
波多黎各也有一个，这对我来说是个新闻。所以……由同一家公司建造。由同一家公司建造。能跟我们讲讲莱维顿的总体情况，以及它们是为何而建的，莱维顿在美国和波多黎各的意义是什么吗？我认为它们在波多黎各的目的略有不同，但在纽约，它们的目的主要是为退伍军人提供战后廉价住房。本质上。
for returning veterans, essentially. You know, you could take a new highway out to your new house that was going to be built in exactly the same way. You were going to have like a couple bedrooms, but you could add another one if you needed. You'd have brand new appliances, and you would have a new school for your kids, a water tower, a library, police, the whole thing. So they were just these plopped-down communities, basically. 5 years ago, this was a vast checkerboard of potato farms on New York's Long Island.
你知道的，你可以沿着一条新公路去你的新房子，房子的建造方式完全一样。你会有一两间卧室，如果需要的话还可以加一间。你会拥有崭新的家电，为你的孩子们准备的新学校、水塔、图书馆、警察局，应有尽有。所以它们基本上就是这种空降下来的社区。5年前，这里还是纽约长岛上由土豆农场组成的巨大棋盘。
Today, a community of 60,000 persons living in 15,000 homes are built by one firm. This is Levittown. You know, one of the things about them beyond, like, their sort of cookie cutter manufacturing way that they existed is that they pioneered some restrictive housing covenants. You are not allowed to be a personal color or a black person in a love of town in the US. Correct. Yeah. And I think about this a little bit with the Levy Town
今天，一个由1.5万栋房屋组成的6万人口的社区由一家公司建成。这就是莱维顿。你知道，关于它们的其中一点，除了它们那种千篇一律的制造方式之外，它们还开创了一些排他性的住房契约。在美国的莱维顿，你不被允许是有色人种或黑人。没错。是的。当我想起波多黎各的莱维顿时，我有点觉得，
in Puerto Rico is that in a way, you had all these migrants coming from the island to New York. And you had a lot of white flight into the suburbs away from Puerto Ricans, away from people like my relatives, my family. And then when Puerto Ricans went back to the island in this wave of reverse migration in the late 60s and 70s, the company then sold us houses. the company then sold us houses. Mm-hmm. Um.
在某种程度上，有这么多的移民从岛上来到纽约。并且有大量的白人群众逃离郊区，远离波多黎各人，远离像我亲戚、我家人这样的人。然后，当波多黎各人在60年代末和70年代的这波反向移民潮中回到岛上时，这家公司随后把房子卖给了我们。这家公司随后把房子卖给了我们。嗯。呃。
So it's like, uh, yeah, they made money twice. And, um, my grandparents moved there when they moved from the Bronx back to the island in the early 70s. They are from another part of the island called Sialis, which is up in the mountains. It is beautiful. The views are gorgeous.
所以就像是，是的，他们赚了两次钱。而且，我的祖父母在70年代初从布朗克斯搬回岛上时，就搬到了那里。他们来自岛上的另一个地方叫西亚莱斯（Ciales），位于山区。那里很美。景色美极了。
There are streams. There are waterfalls. There are underground rivers. It's so beautiful. And my aunt lives there. And I could never understand as a kid why I would have to visit Levytown, which is a... Which is not that, I take it. Which is not that.
有小溪。有瀑布。有地下河。太美了。我的阿姨就住在那里。我小时候从来不明白为什么我必须去莱维顿，那是一个……那不是那样的地方，我想是的。那不是那样的地方。
It is a lot of concrete. I mean, there's a beautiful mango tree in the front, but it's still, it's no siadis. And it is so hot and so flat, but at the same time, it's sort of like beautiful in its way. And what way is it beautiful? I mean, the houses all came in either like white or a cream color.
那里有很多混凝土。我的意思是，前面有一棵美丽的芒果树，但它仍然不是西亚莱斯。而且那里又热又平坦，但与此同时，它以某种方式来看也有点美丽。它在什么地方美丽？我的意思是，房子都是白色或奶油色的。
Like they had no color. And unlike the houses in the New York levitown, these are like all cement. So you can paint like every surface of them. And so they can sometimes be quite colorful. You get kind of get these like sherbert colors. And people also change them a lot, you know, like added a second story, added some Trinitattiat, which is a kind of book and vilia. Like they added, added personality to it.
就像它们没有颜色一样。与纽约莱维顿的房子不同，这里的房子全都是水泥的。所以你可以粉刷它们的每一个表面。有时它们会相当多色彩。你会看到那种雪芭般的颜色。人们也对它们进行了很多改造，你知道，比如加盖了第二层，添加了一些勒杜鹃（Trinitaria），这是一种三角梅。就像他们给它增添了个性。
So why does you want to make this story? Like what does the Leviton in Puerto Rico represent to you? Someone else says this in the piece but I'm gonna steal it but it's sort of Puerto Rico in a nutshell. Like you have this boom and bust story about this desire for modernity and for middle class success in the American dream middle-class success in the American dream. But also this bust, there's so many foreclosure, so many empty homes. It's so hard to find a job that pays enough to have a house. And so it sort of follows that boom and bust idea, but it also is about negotiating this desire for a kind of Puerto Rican success, like this nostalgia for the mountains and for having chickens in a farm. You know, you've got your backyard, but you also have this successful modernity that my family must have really craved, I think.
那你为什么要讲述这个故事呢？波多黎各的莱维顿对你来说代表了什么？作品里另一个人也这么说过，不过我要借用一下，它有点像是波多黎各的缩影。就像你有一个关于对现代性的渴望、对美国梦中中产阶级成功的渴望的兴衰故事。但同时也有这种衰落，有这么多的止赎，这么多的空置房屋。很难找到一份薪水足以买得起房子的工作。所以它有点遵循了这种兴衰的理念，但它也是关于调和这种对波多黎各式成功的渴望，比如对山里的乡愁，以及在农场里养鸡的乡愁。你知道的，你有你的后院，但你也有这种成功的现代性，我的家人一定非常渴望这种现代性，我想。
So that I just wanted to look into that and figure out why it exists and what it did for people, what it does for people. Okay, so we're going to play the piece now. This is the English version of episode two of La Brega. It's called Levitown, where the good life begins. And we're going to start a few minutes in, with the backstory of how the Levitown Company came to develop land in Puerto Rico. Instead of a potato field, in Puerto Rico, the company started out in 1962 by buying nearly 440 acres of flat swamp land in the town of Duabaha, about 20 minutes from San Juan. They built drainage canals to empty into an artificial lake, I've seen the engineering
所以我只想研究一下这个，弄清楚它为什么存在，它为人们做了什么，它为人们带来了什么。好的，我们现在要播放这段作品了。这是《拉布雷加》第二集的英文版。它叫做“莱维顿，美好生活开始的地方”。我们将从几分钟后开始，讲述莱维顿公司如何在波多黎各开发土地的背景故事。波多黎各的公司没有选择土豆田，而是在1962年开始购买了多阿巴哈（Toa Baja）镇近440英亩平坦的沼泽地，距离圣胡安大约20分钟车程。他们修建了排干流入人工湖的排水渠，我见过工程图纸，它们令人印象深刻。他们最初计划建造3000栋房屋，但到1977年将超过11000栋。距离海滩仅几步之遥，它们很快就售罄了。最初提供的型号有“金胸针”（broche de oro）、“卡马费奥”（el cama feo）、“拉德艾玛”（la de edema）、“拉阿拉哈”（la alaja）和“拉伊斯梅拉达”（la ismeralda，也就是两层楼的那种），我的祖父母在70年代初决定离开布朗克斯返回家园时，从朋友那里买下了这套房子。或者至少是一个新家。在这里，在莱维顿，标语是“美好生活开始的地方”，
diagrams, and they're impressive. They originally planned to build 3,000 homes, but by 1977 there would be over 11,000. And just a short walk from the beach, they sold out quickly. The first models offered were broche de oro, el cama feo, la de edema, la alaja, and la ismeralda, the one with two stories, which my grandparents purchased from friends when they decided to leave the Bronx in the early 70s and come back home. Or at least to a new home. Here in La Vita, the tagline was Donde la buena vida comienza,
美好生活开始的地方。是的，这是卡马费奥的房子。卡马费奥，好的。卡马费奥。伊尔达·罗德里格斯（Ilda Rodriguez）和她的女儿宝拉（Paula）住在一栋卡马费奥型号的房子里。1964年他们搬进来时，伊尔达五岁。是的，是64年。
where the good life begins. Sí, está casa la cama feo. Cama feo, OK. Cama feo. Il de Rodriguez lives in a Camapéo model with her daughter Paula. Il de was five when they moved in in 1964. Sí, es 64.
我们是这里最早的第二或第三代现代家庭之一。开拓者，绝对的开拓者。他们不仅仅是开拓者，他们的故事与莱维顿交织在一起。伊尔达的父母在决定回到岛上的家乡之前，在美國组建了他们的家庭。她的叔叔在莱维顿公司工作，他为伊尔达的父亲提供了一份工作，建造
Nosotros fuimos como los segundo terceros modernos aquí en Evita. Perhaps just the second or third family there. Pionero, bien, pionero. They're not just pioneers, their story is entwined with levy thounds. Il de's parents started their family in the States before deciding to come back home to the island. Her uncle was working for the levied company and he offered Ylda's father a job building the
波多黎各的莱维顿房屋。并有机会让他拥有自己的家。这些房子就像波多黎各郊区的许多其他房子一样。平顶水泥矩形，带有迈阿密式的窗户。这些房子配有内置的花盆和车棚（Marquesinas），用混凝土砌块进行装潢和装饰。产品目录确实极力推崇混凝土砌块。请看，装饰性砌块是多么吸引人，它们保护着庭院和窗户下的花坛。
leviedown house in Puerto Rico. And the opportunity for him to own his own home. The houses are like so many others in Puerto Rican suburbs. Flat roofed cement rectangles with Miami windows. These had built-in planters and car ports, Marquezinas, framed and decorated cinder blocks. And the catalog really pushed the cinder blocks. Observe, usted lo atractivo de los bloques ornamentales que rescuardan el patio y las ardinerás bajo las ventanas.
看看它们是如何美化这座宏伟住宅的外观的。所有的房屋都配备了全新的通用电气家电，并安装了电话线。在20世纪60年代，这一切都是一个时尚、现代的梦想。这里曾是一片长满许多棕榈树的红树林沼泽。当伊尔达的母亲打开前门时，Marquecina（车棚）里会挤满螃蟹。在Marquecina里，在庭院里，
Mire cómo enveyesen la fachada de esta maca enmífica residencia. All the homes came with new general electric appliances and were wired for telephones. In the 1960s, this was all a sleek, modern dream. This had been a mangrove swamp with lots of palm trees. When Ilda's mother opened the front door, the Marquecina, the carport, would be full of crabs. It's in the Marquecina, it's in the patio,
在街道上，在楼梯上。太疯狂了，我已经被告知要成为泥土的车了。我不确定我学到了多少。伊尔达的女儿宝拉和她一起住在莱维顿。她开始了自己的数学老师职业生涯，她记得她的祖母甚至在洗衣机里发现过螃蟹。
it's in the street, it's in the stairs. I was crazy, I was already told to be the car of the barro. I'm not sure how much I learned. Ilda's daughter, Paola, lives with her in Levytown. She's starting her career as a math teacher, and she remembers that her grandmother had even found crabs in the washing machine.
如果你打开机器，它们会钻进马达里并发出哗啦哗啦的响声。数量之多，以至于人们会用金属桶收集它们，清洗干净然后煮来吃。我从来没听说过。我的小玩具是怎么回事？她永远不会忘记他们吃了多少蟹腿。在早期，Marquecinas也被用作周日礼拜的场所。在伊尔达的父亲东多尼奥（Dondonio）帮助创立当地天主教堂之前。伊尔达是
They'd get into the motor and rattle around if you turned it on. They were so many that people would collect them in metal buckets, clean them and cook them. I've never heard of it. What's with my little toy? She'll never forget how many crab legs they ate. The Marquessinas were also where Sunday service was held in the early days. Before Ilda's father, Dondonio, helped to found the local Catholic parish. Ilda was in the first graduating class of the elementary school, named for John F. Kennedy. There was a man made lake, which still exists, but back then there were paddle boats too.
以约翰·F·肯尼迪命名的小学的第一届毕业生。这里有一个人工湖，现在依然存在，但在当年还有脚踏船。在美国，莱维顿以排斥黑人和犹太购房者而闻名，并且对从草坪维护到晾衣绳等方方面面都有规定。但在多阿巴哈，完全没有这些。在70年代末，伊尔达记忆中的莱维顿灯火辉煌。看，第三区有一个十五岁成人礼，看，第三区有一场婚礼，看，第三区有一个周年纪念日。但它们都在Marquecinas里，
In the US, Levitowns were famous for excluding black and Jewish home buyers, and there were rules about everything from lawn maintenance to line-drying clothes. But there was none of that in Doah-Bah-Hah. And in the late 70s, Ilda remembers a levy town that was totally lit. Mira, en tercerito hay un quinceñero, mira en tercerito hay una boda, mira en tercerito hay un aniversario. Pero eran en las maquecinas
因为派对就在Marquecina举行。开着车的童子军会在不同的区巡逻，并汇报周五晚上发生了什么派对：婚礼、周年纪念日、生日。他们会不请自来，受到邀请加入，然后他们会成为最后一个离开的人，整晚跳着波莱罗舞。我喜欢想象我的祖父母在这个景观中的样子。过去非常非常非常。生活在一个现代郊区，而不是回到西亚莱斯郁郁葱葱但质朴的乡村。事实证明，莱维顿的这种吸引力，有助于讲述一个更大的故事，关于20世纪中期波多黎各的未来如何一头扎进美国梦。
porque los parijeras eran de maquecina. Scouts with cars would drive around the different sexionists and report back about what parties were happening on a Friday night, a wedding, an anniversary, a birthday. They'd arrive unannounced, get invited to join, and then they'd be the last to leave, dancing boleros all night long. I like imagining my grandparents in this landscape. and the past is very, very, very. Life in a modern suburb instead of a return to the lush but rustic countryside in Seattle is. And as it turns out, that appeal of Levitown, it helps tell a bigger story about how in the mid-20th century Puerto Rico's future ran headlong into the American dream.
那是宝拉，伊尔达的女儿。她的祖父唐·托内奥（Don Toneyo）对莱维顿在波多黎各历史上的地位了解很多。她说，他是那种经历过极度贫困的一代人。他长大时没有鞋穿，后来在生活中获得了高中学位，当然还拥有了自己的房子。因此，波多黎各第一位民选总督路易斯·穆尼奥斯·马林（Luis Muñoz Marín）以极力推行这样一种观点而闻名：岛上的繁荣不会来自州地位，也不会来自独立。穆尼奥斯主张第三条道路。西尔维娅·阿尔瓦雷斯·库鲁洛（Silvia Alvarez Curbelo）是一位波多黎各历史学家。她也是
That's Paula, Ilta's daughter again. Don Toneyo, her grandfather, knew a lot about Leviton's place in Puerto Rico's history. He was from that generation, she says, that went from being really poor. He grew up without shoes, to going on to get his high school degree later in life, and of course to own his own house. So Luis Muñoj Madín, the first elected governor of Puerto Rico, is well known for pushing the idea that the island's prosperity would come not from statehood and not by independence. Muñoj advocated for a third way. Silvia Álvaro Curuelo is a Puerto Rican historian. She's also the author of
《未来的土地》（Un país del porvenir）一书的作者。Un país del porvenir，《未来的土地》。无法掌控未来。“Porvenir”是个美丽的词。Porvenir指的是将要发生的时间，就像地平线上的一个点，某种充满可能性的未来。她说，波多黎各历史上一直渴望、
un país del porvenir. Un país del porvenir, A land of the future. Can't grab the future. Porvenir is a beautiful word. Porvenir means the time that is going to happen, like a point on the horizon, some kind of future of possibility. And Puerto Rico has historically been eager,
争取现代性。穆尼奥斯总督将推动一项名为“Operation Mano Obra”（劳动力行动）的大规模计划，也被称为“靴带计划”（Operation Bootstrap），以改变该岛并实现那个“porvenir”。靴带计划呼应了美国的罗斯福新政。这是对波多黎各经济、实际上也是对整个岛屿的大规模重塑。政府计划为美国公司提供税收减免，
striving for modernity, she says. Governor Munoz would promote a massive program, operación Mano Halauobra, also known as Operation Bootstrap, to transform the island and reach that bogey venir. Operation Bootstrap echoed the new deal in the United States. It was a massive remaking of the Puerto Rican economy, and actually of the whole island. Government programs gave tax breaks to U.S. companies
并策划了从农业向制造业的转变。对穆尼奥斯来说，这是通往现代性的道路，因为在它看来，我们的文化是落后的象征。当然，那是甘蔗农业。所以，这真的不是天堂吗？不是。工业化是未来的事情，
and engineered a shift from agriculture to manufacturing. And for Munoz, it was this path to modernity because our culture was for him like the symbol of backwardness. Of course, it was the agriculture of sugar on crop agriculture. So it was, it was no paradise, really? No. And industrialization was the thing of the future,
再次定义了这一点。要理解为什么莱维顿是一个如此美好的梦想，有必要了解它不是什么。你见过40年代波多黎各人在这里的生活照片吗？豪尔赫·路易斯阿尔多·德波洛（Jorge Lizardi Pollock）是波多黎各大学建筑学院的教授。例如，在一个叫做El Fanguito的地方，这是一片长期被建筑物覆盖的沼泽。这些都是木屋和高脚屋，悬挂在水面上。1940年，波多黎各人的平均预期寿命是46岁，
once again defines that already. To understand why levy town was such a dream, it's worth understanding what it wasn't. Have you seen photograph of how people used to live in the forties here in Puerto Rico? Jorge Luisardo de Polo is a professor at the School of Architecture at the University of Puerto Rico. For example, in this place called El Fanguito, it's a long built-over swamp. These were wooden houses and stilts, perched over water. In 1940, the average life expectancy in Puerto Rico was 46 years,
比美国短了近20年。许多人曾经离开，我们知道没有自来水，没有电，没有浴室。大约70%的人口生活在农村，住房是靴带计划的关键部分。这是政府证明有可能消灭贫民窟并建立一个美好社区的方式。圣胡安宽阔的大道通往住宅区，那里的房屋类似于佛罗里达州、加利福尼亚州或德克萨斯州的房屋。像这部名为《波多黎各节日》（Fiesta Island）这样令人尴尬的电影，将波多黎各推销为一个繁荣的
nearly 20 years shorter than it was in the States. A lot of people used to leave, we know running water, not electricity, no bath. Some 70% of people lived in the countryside, and housing was a key part of Operation Bootstrap. It was the way in which the government demonstrates that it was possible to murder a nice second tree and gain off the slums. Broad avenues in San Juan lead to residential districts where houses resemble those in Florida, California or Texas. Crinchworthy films like this one called Fiesta Island marketed Puerto Rico as a prospering
前哨基地，看起来越来越像美国。在波多黎各，每个人都种植并喜爱鲜花。这些是红姜花。到处都是虫子。在波多黎各蓬勃发展的经济中，住房享有最高优先级。唐娅·费拉（Donya Fela），这一时期的圣胡安市长，在1980年代的一部纪录片中回顾了这段历史。奇迹在于我们创造了中产阶级，这是从一天到另一天凭空创造出来的。
outpost that was looking more and more like the United States. Everybody grows and loves flowers in Puerto Rico. These are red ginger blossoms. Worms for everybody. Housing gets top priority in Puerto Rico's booming economy. Donya Fela, the mayor of San Juan during this period, looked back on it in a documentary in the 1980s. The miracle was that we created middle class, which was created from one day to the other.
而那个新晋的中产阶级从农村（campo）搬到城市需要住房。1960年，波多黎各城市中大约40%的住房被认为是 substandard（不合格的）。在华盛顿特区，联邦政府正在为单户住宅和公路提供激励措施，波多黎各也得到了这些。只是遵循关于美国美好生活的承诺，
And that newly minted middle class moving from the campo to the city needed homes. In 1960, roughly 40% of housing in Puerto Rican cities was considered substandard. In Washington, DC, the federal government was creating incentives for single family homes in highways, and Puerto Rico got them, too. Just following the promise about the good life in the US,
每个人都应该有自己的房子、自己的派对或自己的卡片，我们只是遵循了这个承诺。所以如果我对你说“莱维顿”，你脑海中浮现的第一件事是什么？中产阶级的巅峰。自由的巅峰。直到冷战爆发，华盛顿对波多黎各几乎漠不关心，甚至根本不关心。但随着古巴成为加勒比地区共产主义的海报岛，波多黎各成为了资本主义的对立面。当我想到莱维顿，我想到了冷战，想到了冷战时期的承诺。美国打击独裁统治和共产主义的方法之一，就是给波多黎各人
that everybody should have their own house, their own party, or their own card, we just follow that promise. So if I say levitam to you, what is the first thing that you think? The top of the media class. The top of the freedom. up until the Cold War, Washington cared very little for Puerto Rico, if at all. But as Cuba became the poster island for communism in the Caribbean, Puerto Rico became a capitalist counterpoint. When I think of Leviathan, I think on the Cold War, to be asked on the Cold War promises. And one way the US fought back against dictatorships and communism was by giving Puerto Ricans
拥有自己房屋的机会。这样他们就会成为业主。而业主是不会背叛自己的财产的。他们不会这么做。这不仅适用于波多黎各的莱维顿。莱维父子公司（Levit and sons）的威廉·莱维（William Levitt）曾说，引述：“任何拥有自己房屋和土地的人都不可能是共产主义者，他有太多事情要做。”穆尼奥斯总督支持莱维顿，并出席了1963年9月
the chance to own their own homes. So they will become owners. And owners won't reveal against their own property. They won't do that. This isn't only true of the Puerto Rican levy town. William Levy, of Levy and sons, once said, quote, no man who owns his own house and lot can be a communist, he has too much to do. Governor Munoz embraced levy town, and attended the ribbon cutting for it in September
的剪彩仪式。它在美国报纸上得到了广泛报道。这些带有花园和车库的房子（每个人都期望拥有一辆车），将成为未来50年波多黎各住房的模范。但并不是每个人都有空间容纳穆尼奥斯的这种“Porvenir”愿景。圣胡安市长唐娅·费拉说，一夜之间创造一个中产阶级是个奇迹。但实际上，这是一个非常刻意的奇迹，其结果极其复杂。
of 1963. It was widely covered in US papers. These homes, with their gardens and their garages, for a car everyone was expected to have, would be the model for housing and Puerto Rico for the next 50 years. But there wasn't room for everybody, and this version of Munoz's vision of Porvenir. San Juan's mayor, Donya Fela, said the creation of a middle class overnight was a miracle. But actually, it was a very intentional miracle and one with extremely mixed results.
这种经济转型中鲜少被讨论的部分是，为了让它发挥作用，据说有多少人不得不离开。对于当地的技术官僚来说，问题在于无法创造足够的工作岗位来雇用所有人。岛上的人太多了，无法创造一个中产阶级，这个想法导致了一些可怕的政策。
The part of this economic transformation that isn't talked about much is how many people supposedly had to leave in order to make it work. For local technocrats, the problem was that there was no way to create enough jobs to employ everyone. There were too many people on the island to create a middle class, and that idea led to some horrible policies.
今天，我们对那个令人羞耻的项目有了更多的了解，该项目使大约三分之一的波多黎各妇女绝育，并进行了避孕药实验。但这不仅于此。1946年的一份政府报告估计，为了让岛屿繁荣，大约一百万人必须离开。到40年代末，政府将真正介入，深入介入。我们马上回来。阿拉娜的故事将探讨莱维顿如何成为从美国返回的波多黎各人的家园，广告之后马上回来。
Today we know more about the shameful project that sterilized roughly a third of Puerto Rican women and the birth control pill experiments. But it wasn't only that. In 1946, a government report estimated that around a million people would have to leave in order to make the island prosperous. And by the late 40s, the government would get involved, really involved. We'll be right back. of a Lana story, which explores how Levitown became the place for Puerto Ricans returning from the US right after this.
我们回到了“莱维顿，美好生活开始的地方”的下半部分。这里再次由阿拉娜·库斯蒂诺夫·伯吉斯为您讲述。我们回到了《拉布雷加》。我们一直在谈论一个美式风格的郊区，它的故事在许多方面就是20世纪该岛的故事，当时波多黎各正按照美国的形象被重塑。政府正试图改变波多黎各的经济，从农业转向工业，
We're back with the second half of Levittown where the good life begins. Here's Alana Kustinov, a Burgess again. And we're back to Labriga. We've been talking about an American-style suburb whose story is, in many ways, the story of the island in the 20th century, at a time when Puerto Rico was being remade in America's image. The government was trying to transform Puerto Rico's economy, moving from agriculture to industry,
并建立一个中产阶级。政府意识到，如果没有大规模的人口外流，波多黎各的经济增长可能会受到阻碍或放缓。吉尔伯托·林迪斯（Guadalupe Lindis）是《移民》一书的作者，该书讲述了波多黎各人移居美国的故事，他将其描述为一次精心策划的外流，引用他的话，“一场把每个波多黎各人都变成潜在移民的运动”。波多黎各政府会创造各种杠杆、楔子和滑轮，让现代性对那些留下来的人起作用，但这只能通过鼓励其他人离开来实现。
and making a middle class. The government realized that without the massive exodus of people, economic growth in Puerto Rico would be maybe hinder or slow down. If Guadalupe Lindis is the author of Migration, a book about Puerto Ricans moving to the US, he describes an engineered exodus, a quote, campaign to turn every Puerto Rican into a potential migrant. The Puerto Rican government would create levers and wedges and pulleys to make modernity work for those who stayed, but only by encouraging others to leave.
与此同时，美国政府希望在纽约和芝加哥等城市获得廉价劳动力，因此鼓励移民也符合他们的利益。波多黎各人来到纽约和其他地方寻找工作，为他们的孩子获得更好的教育机会和其他机会。波多黎各政府在劳工部下设了诸如移民司司长之类的职位，总部设在纽约。这是他在1955年的WNYC节目中发言。他们现在正处于阶梯的第一级，我们的许多父亲和祖父
At the same time, the U.S. government wanted cheap labor in cities like New York and Chicago, and so encouraging migration was also in their interest. Puerto Ricans come here to New York and to elsewhere to find jobs to get better education opportunities and other opportunities for their children. The Puerto Rican government had positions like Director of the Migration Division of the Department of Labor, based in New York. Here he is on WNYC in 1955. They are now on the first rung of a ladder which many of our own fathers and grandfathers
就在短短一代人之前开始攀登这个阶梯。所以，他们创建了所有这些项目，来帮助移民从当地政府（如纽约）获得社会服务、英语课程，帮助孩子们处理文件，以便他们能够轻松转入美国的学校，诸如此类的事情。人们曾期望波多黎各人能轻易同化，但这并没有实现。波多黎各人在美国被拒绝，尽管他们是公民，对吧？当然还有文化和语言上的差异。因此，穆尼奥斯政府的一些成员寻找另一种解决方案，来解决他们所认为的人口过剩问题。
began to climb just a generation ago. So, they created all these programs to help migrants get social services from local governments like New York, English classes, helping kids with their documents so they can move easily to schools in the US, all that sort of thing. There was an expectation that bodyquests would assimilate easily, but that didn't pan out. Prickens were being rejected in the United States even though there were citizens, right? And of course the cultural and linguistic differences. So there were members of Munoz's government who looked for another solution to what they saw as the problem of overpopulation.
我给出的是，嗯，对于移民来说，由于共同的文化和语言，在拉丁美洲融入和同化会更容易。但早在50世纪50年代初，政府就派代表前往巴西，考虑在那里建立一个破产移民的殖民地。美国政府对此表示反对，不仅因为他们不希望波多黎各与外国政府谈判，而且让一群美国公民住在委内瑞拉或多米尼加共和国也会变得太乱。是的，他们确保有大量飞往美国的航班。
That I give, well, for migrants it will be easier to incorporate on assimilate in Latin America because of the common culture and language. But even in the early 50s the government sent a representative to Brazil to consider creating a colony of broken migrants there. The US government next to this not only did they not want Puerto Rico negotiating with foreign governments but it would also get too messy to have a bunch of US citizens living in Venezuela or the Dominican Republic. And yes, they made sure there were plenty of flights to the US.
这就让我们想到了1951年飞往圣胡安的第一班东方航空公司（Eastern Airlines）航班，正是这班航班打破了泛美航空（Pan Am）的垄断。这就让我们想到了1951年飞往圣胡安的第一班东方航空公司航班，正是这班航班打破了泛美航空的垄断。我们认为，提供那种岛上持续发展和繁荣所依赖的交通服务，既是一项特权，也是一项义务。穆尼奥斯总督曾游说扩大航空服务，以使波多黎各人更容易离开该岛。但当他提出这一论点时，他说的是
And that's what gets us to the first Eastern Airlines flight to San Juan in 1951, the one that broke Pan Am's monopoly. And that's what gets us to the first Eastern Airlines flight to San Juan in 1951, the one that broke Pan Am's monopoly. We consider it both a privilege and an obligation to offer Puerto Rico the kind of transport service upon which the continuing purpose and prosperity of this island depends. Governor Muñoz had lobbied for expanding airline access to make it easier for Puerto Ricans to leave the island. But when he made the argument, what he said
波多黎各人理应像美国其他任何人一样去寻找工作。每当我想到为了让一百万人离开、为了让像我这样的家庭离开而进行的所有这些阴谋诡计，想到我们是为了那个闪耀的“Porvenir”而值得做出的牺牲，我的心里就隐隐作痛，但人们不会就这样一去不复返，因为该岛与美国的关系，波多黎各人来去更加容易。许多像我祖父母这样的人决定回来，对于他们和许多其他从……的关系来看，波多黎各人来去更加容易。许多像我祖父母这样的人决定回来，对于他们和许多其他从
was that Puerto Ricans deserve to go looking for jobs as much as anyone else in the states. It stings when I think about all these machinations to get a million people to leave, to get families like mine to leave, that we were a sacrifice worth making for that shining Bovenid, but people wouldn't just leave for good, because of the island's relationship with the U.S., it was easier for Puerto Ricans to come and go. Many like my grandparents would decide to return, and for them and many others coming from relationship with the US, it was easier for Puerto Ricans to come and go. Many like my grandparents would decide to return, and for them and many others coming from
狭窄寒冷的步梯公寓走出来的人来说，成功的梦想看起来非常像莱维顿。现在，莱维顿是一个重要的现象，因为它基本上是一个由回流移民建造的区域。这种流动不再是单向的，成千上万的波多黎各人决定返回家园。通常情况下，在没有外国召唤的情况下，提供飞往波多黎各圣胡安的服务。1971年8月，CBS新闻。有些人已经攒够了钱，在新郊区购买了小型、整洁的房屋，例如在莱维顿等开发区，那里的生活有着明显的美国风味，就像郊区的名字一样。
cramped and cold walk-up apartments, the dream of success looked a lot like Louis Thun. Now, the Louis Thun is an important phenomenon, because it's basically an area built by return migrant. The flow is no longer one way, as thousands of Puerto Ricans have decided to return home. In general, on the absence of a foreign foreign call, for service to San Juan, Puerto Rico. August 1971, CBS News. Some have saved enough money to buy small, trim homes in new suburbs, in developments like Levittown, for instance, where life has a distinctly American flavor as a suburb's name.
莱维顿以其是回国侨民定居的地方而闻名。我认为这是一个中间空间。历史学家西尔维娅·阿尔瓦雷斯·库鲁洛说，莱维顿是美国和波多黎各之间的桥梁。对于返回的波多黎各人来说，正如几个人告诉我的那样，有一种乡愁，怀念波多黎各发生大变革之前、人们离开之前存在于乡村的生活。前面是车棚，后面是大蕉。你必须种一棵番石榴树、一棵柠檬树，你知道的，就像花园里的主要植物波多黎各。莱维顿的庭院有容纳这些的空间。在莱维顿，我认为许多纽约人希望拥有一个已经在某种程度上消失的波多黎各。
Levittown has a reputation for being a place settled by the returning diaspora. I think that is like an intermediate space. The historian Silvia Alvarez-Guruelos says levita was a bridge between the US and Puerto Rico. For returning Puerto Ricans, there was a nostalgia, as several people have told me, for a life in the countryside that existed before Puerto Rico's big transformation, before people left. Carport in the front, platanos in the back. You have to plant a guava tree, a lemon tree, and you know, like the staples of a garden Puerto Rico. And levitans' pateos had room for that. In levitan I think that many of the New Yorkers wanted to have a Puerto Rico that was already
我的祖父尼古拉斯·卡萨诺瓦（Nicolas Casanova）在他的郊区后院里养了鸭子、鸡甚至鹅。这是一个我直到西尔维娅描述了这种渴望时才想到的细节，但对于每个从纽约回来的人来说，这并不是一件容易适应的事。一位居民在非录音采访中告诉我，她曾遭到一位老师的霸凌，因为她说英语而受到训斥。这是70年代的一个普遍故事，出现在引用波多黎各高中青少年的新闻报道中。人们嘲笑我，因为我不会说西班牙语。
banishing in some way. My grandfather, Nicolas Casanova, kept ducks and chicken and even geese in his suburban backyard. It's a detail I hadn't thought about until Sylvia described that longing, but it wasn't an easy fit for everyone returning from New York. One resident told me, not on tape, that she felt bullied by a teacher who scolded her for speaking English. It was a common story in the 70s, featured in news reports quoting teenagers in Puerto Rican high schools. People laughed at me because I didn't know Spanish.
他们会，你知道的，你会说错一些词。他们会试图纠正你，你知道的，但大多数时候他们在笑。他们取笑你说西班牙语的方式。所以，他们说如果你在西班牙语里说错了词，诸如此类的话。他们开始说你不会说西班牙语，诸如此类的话。他们开始叫你“gringo”（美国佬）。波多黎各的学校甚至开始为回流移民提供西班牙语课程，以帮助他们重新融入。
They were, you know, you would say something wrong. They'd be trying to correct you, you know, but most of the time they were laughed. They make fun of you the way you talk Spanish. So, they say if you say about wrong words in Spanish, something like that. They start saying you can't speak Spanish right and things like that. And they start calling you gringo. Schools in Puerto Rico even started offering Spanish courses to the returning migrants to help them fit back in.
对在美国的生活感到不满，并在充满敌意的波多黎各缓慢同化，这些纽约波多黎各人（Nuyoricans）说他们处于无所适从的境地，不知道自己属于哪里。从美国回来的纽约波多黎各人不仅难以融入，还难以找到工作，而且他们并不是唯一这样的人。伊尔达，我们之前听到的那位居民，
Unhappy with life in the States and slow to assimilate in a hostile Puerto Rico, the Neorecon say they're in limbo, not knowing where they belong. Neorecon's returning from the States not only struggled to fit in, they also struggled to find a job, and they weren't the only ones. Ilda, the resident we heard from earlier,
说她的家庭在从美国回来后很难维持生计。在莱维顿，他们房子的按揭贷款（卡马费奥型号）是每月62美元。对他们的家庭来说，这是一大笔钱。当我们搬到这里时，房子的价格是12500美元。她的父亲东多尼奥曾参与建造莱维顿的房屋，
says her family had a hard time making ends meet after returning from the states. In Levitown, the mortgage payment on their house, the Camapéo model, was $62 a month. That was a lot for their family. When we moved here, the cost of the house was $12,500. Her father, Dontonio, had worked building the Levitown houses,
但当这些房屋在70年代末全部完工时，他的下一份工作赚的钱不足以支付每月的贷款。当父亲到家时，父亲已经陷入绝望的边缘，他已经和妈妈谈过了。到了某个时刻，他已经到了绝望的边缘，她的父母正在考虑是放弃房子再次离开去美国，还是发生了一件改变他们命运的事情。
but when they had all been finished in the late 70s, his next job didn't pay enough to make the monthly payment. When the father arrived, the father was already at the back of the despair, and he had already spoken to mommy. There came a moment where he was on the verge of desperation, and her parents were deciding whether they'd give up the house and leave again for the United States, when something happened that changed their fortunes.
但当这些在70年代末全部完工时，他的下一份工作赚的钱已经不够支付每月的房贷了。当父亲到达时，他已经陷入绝望的深渊，并且已经和妈妈谈过了。正当他濒临绝望，她的父母在决定是否放弃房子再次前往美国时，发生了一件事，改变了他们的命运。
Yilda can see the scene in her memory. One day her father got home. He sits down at the dining room table and he opens the newspaper. Her mother, Dóñalúsi, is in the kitchen. Come here, he says. She looks over his shoulder. I was going to marry her and I was going to be in love. Ilde could hear her saying, no way, really, no way. De verdad, en vurte, she could see them both with huge smiles on their faces, full of happiness. Y pegando dos hay con la cara alegria,
伊尔达在记忆中看到了那一幕。有一天，她的父亲回到家。他坐在餐桌旁，打开了报纸。她的母亲多娜卢西正在厨房里。过来，他说。她看着他的肩膀。我打算娶她，我打算去爱。伊尔德听到她说，真的吗，不会吧，真的不会。确实如此，她看到他们俩脸上都带着巨大的微笑，充满幸福。他们高兴得手舞足蹈，
pero yo estoy mirando lo no sé lo que pasa. Don Antonio had won the lottery, first prize. the lottery, first prize. Well, Papia had bought the lottery and it was the first prize. With that money, he paid off the house. A few streets away, his sister was also struggling to pay. He helped her out too. And thank you, as I always say, for the first time in my life,
但我看着却不知道发生了什么。安东尼奥先生中了彩票，头奖。彩票头奖。嗯，爸爸买彩票中了头奖。有了这笔钱，他付清了房子的贷款。几条街外，他的姐姐也在为还贷苦苦挣扎。他也帮了她一把。感谢上帝，正如我常说的，这是我生平第一次，
especially for things. For this money, for the telling me about everything. It's my gift, it should be my gift. If not for the lottery, they would have gone back to the States. Maybe someday her parents would have returned to the island, but they wouldn't have kept the house. Definitely, I mean, I think we're not here. But here we are 55 years old, and... Instead, she's been in Levitam now are 55 years old, and she's been in Levita now for 55 years.
特别是为了这些事情。为了这笔钱，为了告诉我这一切。这是我的礼物，这本该是我的礼物。如果不是因为中了彩票，他们就会回美国了。也许有一天她的父母会回到岛上，但他们不会保住这栋房子。毫无疑问，我的意思是，我觉得我们就不会在这里了。但我们现在在这里，已经55岁了，而且……相反，她现在在莱维汤已经55岁了，她已经在莱维汤生活了55岁。
And despite all the good times, all the memories, and all the promises, I'll just go for a minute here. Ilda says that the way life is in Puerto Rico, she wants to leave. It's the crime, the shrinking pensions, the lack of opportunities. But also people used to say neighbors are your real family. Everyone would help each other, care for each other. Today, Ilda says, if you die, they find you by the smell. This is so dark, but the truth is that there are so many empty homes in Levitown now. Nearly 15 years of a fiscal recession has taken its toll and then came Maria.
尽管有所有的美好时光、所有的回忆和所有的承诺，我在这里暂且略过。伊尔达说，以波多黎各目前的生活状况，她想离开。这里有犯罪、不断缩水的养老金、缺乏机会。但人们过去常说，邻居就是你真正的家人。每个人都会互相帮助，互相照顾。如今，伊尔达说，如果你死了，别人是通过气味才找到你的。这太阴暗了，但事实是现在莱维汤有太多空置的房屋了。长达近15年的财政衰退付出了代价，接着玛丽亚飓风又来了。
According to figures from 2018, over 20% of the houses in Levitown are vacant. The elementary school, the one named for John F. Kennedy, was closed as part of an island wide shutdown of hundreds of schools. And now, it's not like before, I think of my mother, she had the best stage of life. Paula, Yilda's daughter, says her mother saw Leviton's best days. She lives at home, loves this place. But news, her and her friends have seen its decline. It wasn't just dancing in the streets. There were also walkways between the sections, and now they're all closed.
根据2018年的数据，莱维汤超过20%的房屋是空置的。那所名为约翰·F·肯尼迪的小学，作为全岛数百所学校关停潮的一部分被关闭了。现在，情况已经不比从前了，我想起我的母亲，她度过了人生中最美好的阶段。保拉，伊尔达的女儿，说她的母亲见证了莱维汤最好的日子。她住在家里，热爱这个地方。但现在，她和她的朋友们看到了这里的衰落。这里不只是街头舞蹈。各区之间曾经还有步行道，而现在它们全都被关闭了。
The people walking in all the pastures that are now basically closed, and it's dangerous to walk alone. And the beach that borders the north side of Levitown, Punta Salinas is contaminated. For example, the beach from there to the front that is now contaminated. And Ilda can't imagine late night chats outside with neighbors. Do you think I'm too much? Now.
人们在所有草地上散步的日子现在基本上都结束了，独自散步很危险。而莱维汤北侧的边界海滩蓬萨利纳斯也受到了污染。例如，从那里到前面的海滩现在都被污染了。伊尔达无法想象和邻居在外面深夜聊天的情景。你觉得我说的太过分了吗？现在。
No. In the original designs, Levitown's balconies were all open, but today they're caged with security bars. Levitown's lake, once in a minute, overflowed during Maria. The dam was opened without warning and houses and streets near it flooded. Ilda and Paola's home didn't flood,
没有。在最初的设计中，莱维汤的阳台都是开放的，但今天它们都被装上了防盗护栏。莱维汤的湖，曾经在玛丽亚飓风期间泛滥。大坝在毫无警告的情况下被打开，附近的房屋和街道都被淹了。伊尔达和保拉的家没有被淹，
but other people had to be rescued from their roofs or flee in the dark. Four people died. Every time I go to work, I take the 165 road, que la 1 o 165, that's the road that takes all Dorado, levitown, San Juan, and you could see how deteriorated levitown is actually post-maria and before maria. That's six to a secortice, a friend of baulas and long time levitown resident. After Maria, out of boredom, they made our podcast with some other friends.
但其他人不得不从屋顶获救或在黑暗中逃生。四个人死了。每次我去上班，我都走165号公路，也就是1号公路或165号公路，那是通往多拉多、莱维汤、圣胡安的公路，你能看到玛丽亚飓风之后和之前莱维汤实际上是多么的破败。这是保拉的朋友、莱维汤长期居民西克斯托说的。玛丽亚飓风之后，出于无聊，他和一些其他朋友制作了我们的播客。
And one of the episodes is about their home. They discussed the awful experience of the hurricane, and they talk about a book of short stories based in Leviton. And, over an hour into the episode, six deposes a huge question to the group. Did Levitown fail? And his answer, he told Paola and I recently, is yes. You could actually see how levitown could mirror perfectly the failed experiment of the Commonwealth of Puerto Rico.
其中有一集是关于他们的家的。他们讨论了飓风带来的可怕经历，还谈到了一本以莱维汤为背景的短篇小说集。在节目进行了一个多小时后，西克斯托向大家提出了一个巨大的问题。莱维汤失败了吗？他最近告诉保拉和我说，他的答案是肯定的。你实际上可以看出莱维汤是如何完美地反映出波多黎各自由邦失败的实验的。
That's just my opinion. And how at the same time it could be mirrored as the failed experiment of the American dream. He sees it in the rundown baseball fields in the abandoned houses, in that drive to work every day on the 165. And that many people, you know, they left Puerto Rico, their own home, their own picket fence, their white picket fence with their dog and their family and their house. The financial crisis and austerity policy has blanketed the whole island.
这只是我的个人观点。以及它如何同时被视作美国梦失败实验的写照。他在破旧的棒球场、废弃的房屋中，在每天开车上班经由165号公路的途中看到了这一点。许多人，你知道的，他们离开了波多黎各，离开他们自己的家，他们自己的带白色栅栏的院子，还有他们的狗、他们的家庭和他们的房子。金融危机和紧缩政策笼罩了整个岛屿。
More than angry, it makes me sad, you know, that we're in this time, but this is not only Levy Thong. This Puerto Rico in a nutshell. There was something about Levy Thong that required a winning lottery ticket to achieve. The promise wasn't a home, it was a house, and that suburban model of development was defined by sprawl that clutters the landscape, and by mortgages that have become foreclosures. It wasn't enough to build houses if you couldn't create an economy in which people could afford to stay in them.
比起愤怒，它更让我感到悲伤，你知道的，我们正处于这个时代，但这不仅仅是莱维汤的现状。这就是波多黎各的一个缩影。莱维汤的某些地方需要一张中奖彩票才能实现。这里的承诺不是一个家，而是一栋房子，那种郊区的发展模式的特点是杂乱无章的景观，以及最终变成止赎房产的抵押贷款。如果你无法创造一个能让人们负担得起留在那里的经济，仅仅建造房屋是不够的。
The poor venerated governor Luis Muñoj Madín had promised, had already started to crumble with a recession in the 1970s. Silvia Alvarez-Curuelo told me about a diary that he kept for a couple of years during that time. And it was like he was surprised by the change. He spoke about the traffic surprise by the change. He spoke about the traffic about the people that were in a hurry. He spoke about the trouble with youth, juvenile, the linguine-seeing, and so on. He sounds like kind of a just a grumpy old man. People are rushing around too much these days, the kids. Right? He sounds a little... Yes, because the times accelerated too much, because too much progress, too much poor venice, too much poor venice, the wish poor venice and the unraveling of
贫穷美化家、已故总督路易斯·穆尼奥斯·马林曾承诺的事情，在20世纪70年代的经济衰退中已经开始崩溃。西尔维娅·阿尔瓦雷斯-库鲁洛跟我谈到一本他在那个时期写了几年的日记。就好像他对这种变化感到惊讶一样。他谈到了交通，对这种变化感到惊讶。他谈到了交通，谈到了行色匆匆的人们。他谈到了青少年问题、青少年犯罪等等。他听起来有点像个脾气暴躁的老头。现在的人们总是行色匆匆，孩子们。对吧？他听起来有点……是的，因为时代加速得太快了，因为进步太多，贫民窟太多，对美好生活的愿望以及解体
the poor venice into many poor venice, it was not only one. It's as though the vision of having a house got tied up too closely with the American dream and with an unsustainable consumerism. So LaVitown can feel like a metaphor for the failures of Puerto Rico's economic experiment. But last time I was there, I saw it through new eyes. I took in the interesting things that were showing through the cracks. Cezán Cardona Morales is the author of a collection of short stories called, Ironically, Levitown Monamore,
贫民窟变成许多贫民窟，不只是一个。就好像拥有房子的愿景与美国梦以及不可持续的消费主义联系得太紧密了。因此，莱维汤会让人觉得是波多黎各经济实验失败的隐喻。但上次我去那里时，我用全新的眼光看待了它。我注意到那些在裂缝中显露出来的有趣事物。塞赞·卡多纳·莫拉莱斯是一部短篇小说集的作者，讽刺的是，这本书名为《莱维汤，我的爱》。
the one Paola and Sixto discussed in their podcast. Cezán and I met under the rust-street belly of the Blue Water Tower a couple of weeks Pompas. Sí, torre de agua, pompas de agua. Lo cierto es que se ha convertido, además del ícono, es una marca dentro del mapa aéreo, es decir, los aviones que van a terrizar tienen que informar que están pasando por aquí. Es parte de la área de map, y he checked this out, y está en la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de la parte de they're passing it on their way into the airport. In other words, I'm not the only one. Prove leviton me si dando sorpresa como ciudad. Levitown keeps surprising him. Every time he comes here, despite the detritus and the decay,
也就是保拉和西克斯托在他们的播客中讨论的那本。几个星期前，我和塞赞在蓝色水塔生锈的底部见面了。是的，水塔，水泵。事实上，它不仅是一个标志，也是空中地图上的一个地标，也就是说，准备降落的飞机必须报告他们正在经过这里。它是地图区域的一部分，我核实过了，它位于……的部分，当他们飞往机场时会经过它。换句话说，我不是唯一的一个。莱维汤不断带给我作为城市的惊喜。莱维汤总是让他感到惊讶。每当他来到这里，尽管有残垣断壁和衰败，
he sees colors that call his attention. Cada vez que pasó por ella, apesar del detrito que veo, de lo que está se está cayendo veo colores que me llaman la atención. Writing about this place was his way of making a kind of peace with his country, with Puerto Rico through the fiscal crisis, the deterioration, the difficulty of making ends meet. To leave the resentment about what wasn't and appreciate what is.
他总能看到吸引他注意力的颜色。每次我经过这里，尽管看到残垣断壁，看到正在倒塌的东西，我还是能看到吸引我注意力的颜色。写下这个地方是他与自己的国家波多黎各达成某种和解的方式，通过财政危机、衰退、维持生计的艰难。放下对过去未能实现的怨恨，去欣赏现在的一切。
Leave it behind, or that recall of what maybe wasn't and appreciate what it is and what it will be doing. I asked him after all this historical research, if I'm trying to see the beauty in La Vitaon, could he give me some pointers? If I'm trying to see the beauty in La Vitaon, I could give him some advice. What? Well, it depends on what you consider beauty. Look at what time has done to this place.
将其抛在脑后，或者对可能未曾实现的事物的回忆，去欣赏它的现状以及它将要做的事。我问他，在进行了所有这些历史研究之后，如果我试图在莱维汤发现美，他能否给我一些指点？如果我试图在莱维汤发现美，我可以给他一些建议。什么？嗯，这取决于你如何定义美。看看时间对这个地方做了什么。
Look at the rest at the shuttered businesses. Talvez eso, miral... miral las cosas que el tiempo ha ha dado. Talvez miral la oxidación, los lugares cerrados. Looking at closed-door friends gave up. And now, I'm going to go to the next room. the time has passed, maybe the oxidation is looking at it, the places are closed. Looking at closed door fronts gave him the possibility to invent, to imagine businesses that maybe didn't actually exist,
看看那些残垣断壁，看看那些关门歇业的店铺。也许吧，看……看看时间所赋予的东西。也许看看锈迹，看看那些关闭的地方。看着紧闭的店门，那些放弃的人。现在，我要去下一个房间。时间流逝了，也许是生锈的外观，看着它，那些地方都关门了。看着紧闭的店门，这给了他发明、想象那些可能并不真实存在的生意的可能，
and walk along the boulevard, which is called Avenue Boulevard, a redundant name that tickles the sun. Caminal, put the boulevard. Maybe the only avenue that a avenue is called Avenue Avenida. It tickles me now, too, and much more does as well. A few steps away from where we sat, the public high school is named for Dr. Pedro Albisu Campos, Puerto Rico's independence icon. Right there in Levittown, the American suburb, and then there's the water tower, which doesn't actually hold any water. Now we see if we observe there,
沿着被称为大道林荫路的街道漫步，这是一个有些滑稽的冗长名字。走在林荫路上。也许唯一一条被称为“林荫路大道”的大道。现在这也让我觉得很好笑，而且更加引人入胜。离我们坐的地方几步之遥，公立高中以波多黎各独立运动的偶像佩德罗·阿尔比苏·坎波斯博士的名字命名。就在莱维汤，这个美国的郊区，还有那个实际上不储水的水塔。现在我们看看如果我们去那里观察，
the water tower is totally inservable. It's a monument to uselessness, a symbol of a failure to have functional infrastructure, and yet it's still an icon, visible from the highway, from the streets, and from the sky. y por supuesto, es un icon visible de la gran parte de los estrellos y de la ciudad. No es muy toad, sino nuestra incapacidad de poder construir o de poder llevar agua a un lugar. empty and yet, but it has become the same in our own ideal. It's become like our own, I full tower, he says, appealing to Cicin precisely because it doesn't work.
水塔完全无法使用。它是无用的纪念碑，是未能建立功能性基础设施的象征，然而它依然是一个标志，从高速公路、街道和天空中都能看到。当然，它是大部分街道和城市清晰可见的标志。这不仅仅是我们无法建造或无法将水运送到某个地方。空置的，然而，它已经变成了我们自己理想中的存在。它已经变得像我们自己的，我全能的塔，他说，之所以吸引塞赞，恰恰是因为它不管用。
I remember something Paula shared on her podcast about how she sometimes imagines that there's a mermaid in the water tower. It's a vision from Aqua Marine, a teen movie from 2006 that you should feel no rush to go see. In the movie, there's a mermaid in a water tower. I imagine mermaids up there now, too. I had hoped to end this journey in my grandparents' leviedown, but then the pandemic hit.
我记起保拉在她的播客中分享过的一件事，关于她有时如何想象水塔里有一条美人鱼。这是2006年青春电影《水上美人鱼》中的场景，你其实没必要急着去看。电影里，水塔里有一条美人鱼。我现在也想象上面有美人鱼。我曾希望在祖父母的莱维汤结束这段旅程，但随后疫情爆发了。
So instead, this summer, I drove from Brooklyn to Long Island and peered up at this other water tower in this other levy town. While the Puerto Rican won towers over a busy commercial strip, this one is quiet, tucked into some residential streets that curve into each other and are named for plants, like a zelia road and a iris lane. I could hear the drip, drip, drip of water falling from the tank. There's a baseball diamond there too and a basketball court and a group of teenagers were playing. Someone was walking their dog.
所以今年夏天，我从布鲁克林开车到长岛，抬头凝视着另一个莱维汤的另一个水塔。波多黎各的水塔耸立在繁忙的商业街区上方，而这个水塔则很安静，隐藏在一些相互弯曲交错的住宅街道中，这些街道以植物命名，如杜鹃花路和鸢尾花巷。我能听到水箱里水滴滴答答落下的声音。那里也有一个棒球场、一个篮球场，还有一群青少年在玩耍。有人在遛狗。
The lawns were tidy, but there were no guava trees, no lemon trees. This light blue water tower also says Levittown in big letters, although frankly it's not as impressive. Maybe not as tall as the Puerto Rican one. I imagine getting some bolt cutters for the chain link fence and getting to the circular door at the base of the tower. I could open the hatch, like the ones on a submarine, and instead of climbing whatever ladder lies on the other side, I could open another hatch and arrive at the other levitam,
草坪很整洁，但没有番石榴树，也没有柠檬树。这个浅蓝色的水塔上也用大字写着“莱维汤”，坦率地说，它没有那么引人注目。也许没有波多黎各那个那么高。我幻想着拿一把强力剪去剪断链式围栏，到达水塔底部的圆形门。我可以打开舱门，就像潜水艇上的那种，不用爬另一边的梯子，我可以打开另一个舱门，来到另一个莱维汤，
as though the water towers were portals. I'd arrive by passing airplanes and airports and the danger of a COVID-19 transmission on Avenida Boulevard. I'd go to Panadarilla Lemmy and I'd order a box of quesito, then I'd walk to my cousin's house, the same one my grandparents moved to when they were looking for something between one dream and another. In the room where I sleep when I visit, there's a view of the water tower. La Vrega is a co-production of WNYC Studios and Futuro Studios. This episode is available in Spanish as well, and you can listen to either wherever you get your podcasts, through La Vrega's podcast feed.
就好像水塔是传送门一样。我会在林荫路大道上经过飞机、机场和感染新冠的危险中到达那里。我会去潘达里利亚·莱米买一盒芝士酥，然后走到我表哥家，也就是我祖父母寻找梦想与现实之间的栖息地时搬去的那栋房子。在我访问时睡觉的房间里，可以看到水塔的景色。《拉夫雷加》是WNYC工作室和未来工作室的联合制作。这一集也有西班牙语版本，你可以在任何获取播客的地方通过《拉夫雷加》的播客源收听。
This episode was produced by me, with help from Mark Pagan. It was edited by Luis Treyes, Marlon Bishop, and Mark Pagan, fact-checking by Istra Pacheco. Engineering is by Stephanie Lebow, Leah Shadamaran, Rosanna Caban, Gabriel Avais, and Alicia B. Ituk. Original music for LaVrega was composed by Balun, and our theme song is by Ife. Additional music from Franky Reyes. Art for this piece was done by Fernando Noreth.
这一集由我制作，马克·帕根协助。由路易斯·特雷耶斯、马龙·毕夏普和马克·帕根剪辑，伊斯特拉·帕切科负责事实核查。工程由斯蒂芬妮·莱博、莉亚·沙达马拉兰、罗莎娜·卡班、加布里埃尔·阿瓦伊斯和艾莉西亚·B·伊图克完成。拉夫雷加的原创音乐由巴伦创作，我们的主题曲由伊费创作。额外音乐来自弗兰基·雷耶斯。这幅作品的插图由费尔南多·诺雷思完成。
Leadership Support for Laberega is provided by the Jonathan Logan Family Foundation, and the John S. and James L. Knight Foundation, with additional support provided by Amy Lys. Deep gratitude to WN My C's Andy Lancet for his generosity with archival tape. Thanks also to Rebecca Ibarra and Yari Marbonilla for their ears and to Carmelo Estiric, Francisco Rodriguez Suarez, and Mirmari Graugonzales for their expertise. And special thanks to Sofia and Lucinda Bordali
拉夫雷加的领导层支持由乔纳森·洛根家族基金会和约翰·S·和詹姆斯·L·奈特基金会提供，艾米·莱斯提供了额外支持。深深感谢WNYC的安迪·兰塞特慷慨提供档案磁带。还要感谢丽贝卡·伊瓦拉和亚里·马尔博尼利亚倾听意见，感谢卡尔梅洛·埃斯蒂里克、弗朗西斯科·罗德里格斯·苏亚雷斯和米尔玛里·格劳冈萨雷斯提供专业知识。特别感谢索菲亚和露辛达·博尔达利
and Olga Casanova Burgess. Thanks also to Esequel Rodriguez-Sandino. In the next episode, a very different story about the shadows of the Cold War in Puerto Rico and a dark legacy we're still dealing with. Hasta la próxima! Thanks to Alana Casanova Burgess in LeBrega for letting us share their story. Go listen to them all, they're fantastic. Our feature that wrapped around their story was produced by Emmett Fitzgerald and our senior producer Delaney Hall, music by our director of Sound Sean Rial, mixed by Amida
以及奥尔加·卡萨诺瓦·伯吉斯。还要感谢埃塞克尔·罗德里格斯-桑迪诺。在下一集中，一个关于波多黎各冷战阴影的截然不同的故事，以及我们仍在处理的黑暗遗产。下次见！感谢《拉夫雷加》的阿拉娜·卡萨诺瓦·伯吉斯让我们分享他们的故事。去听听看吧，它们棒极了。围绕他们的故事制作的专题节目由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和我们的高级制作人德莱尼·霍尔制作，音乐由我们的音响总监肖恩·里亚尔创作，混音由阿米达
Kanatra. Cricklested is 99 P.I.'s digital director, Thorec Littin, is Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Lashemba Dawn, Chris Baroube, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. 99% of this world is a project of 91.7 KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered about the North American continent right now, but is centered in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all a podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
卡纳特拉完成。克里斯特尔斯德是99 P.I.的数字总监，托雷克·利廷是克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、拉舍姆巴·唐、克里斯·巴鲁贝、凯蒂·明格尔、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马尔斯。这个世界的99%是旧金山91.7 KLW的项目，制作于广播街，现在它分散在北美大陆各处，但中心位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽市中心。我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客中所有最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram, and read it too. But our home for beautiful nerds is 99PI.org. Radio Tapia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（罗曼·马尔斯），在节目官网上@99PI org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上。但我们美丽的书呆子的家园是 99PI.org。Radio Tapia。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。